one day where i'm like i don't know how
to join
clubs online i don't know how to
listen i don't know how to participate
in the online world
because i'm old so one day i went like
okay what is um
prime time what's it called amazon prime
time
i'm gonna get amazon prime i go i do it
and it's like no
you can't do it through this app you
have to go to this other app sign up for
that you have to go online
i go to the other line no you have to do
this other
amazon horizon and then you know fill
out give all the information
and i would do that for three hours you
remember right
and also anything that i order i have
[ __ ] two skate shirts
like you know caballero um bone skate
shirt that i ordered four months ago
there's some
it's not even here there's someone in
this neighborhood who has three thousand
dollars worth of toys
t-shirts and groceries yeah and have a
narrow sauce
i tried all of it i've tried i've spent
thousands of dollars
they just don't arrive at the house so
i'm doing it wrong oh my god one time
esther there's this one time and i'll
never forget this for the rest of my
life
and i'm so glad that my niece juliana
was there to witness this whole meltdown
but basically he decided we were on our
way to the post office because i had to
mail stuff
and he threw a tantrum about what a
[ __ ] i was for not helping him out
with his prime time
because he couldn't sign up for amazon
prime and then the whole way
down he was just in a rage
meltdown and and and i told him because
i think
i don't know what it was i was like can
we wait till we're done with the windy
hills
for me to set your account up because i
get dizzy when i read my phone
and which put him into a deeper rage
because she did it in spite she could
have done it then
no and i was like well wait till the
bottom of the hill don't wait for the
bottom of the hill and then we'll park
and i'll i'll fix your prime
time for you yeah and remember so i do
remember that and i call it you
profession i apologize profusely but
what i'm saying to you is
that the reason why i asked now for a
freezer and other things
is because i am unable to do it i don't
have the capabilities
or the you know ability to to order
things
do you sleep in a bassinet
what's a pessimist for babies babies
that's my dream
this is like i just what are you saying
are you calling me a baby
no why see why'd you say do i sleep in a
basket no let me explain i think two
things
one you have it you have it so good
because you have him
completely dependent on you he can't
even step into the real world without
you so you're like you own him and you
have it good because you have a
full-time caregiver
so when did you let me let's talk about
your special so
when did you um film your special we
shot it in october we did
four shows and then we did i shot behind
the scenes stuff with my parents
over the summer and then some in the
fall um
and then yeah then and so you shot the
special for
what'd you shoot in chicago no we shot
it at dynasty typewriter in l.a oh it's
like a very small
cute theater cool yeah so you did a
dynasty typewriter
and then you filmed it for comedy
central and now it comes out
i thought comedy central was no longer a
network right
well that's kind of what that's like the
slang that's like what people are saying
out there on the streets but
i it's it's still a network i think
they're going through changes like
viacom in general is
um but youtube tv
just added comedy central so it's there
and
it's gonna stream